welche Fluggesellschaft hat die beste
Business Class der Welt das will ich
herausfinden und erstelle dafür ein Top
10 Ranking heute testen wir die Business
Class von Emirates auf meinem Rückflug
von Dubai nach Frankfurt natürlich
erfahrt ihr auch wie viel ich bezahlt
habe in Dubai gibt es ein reines First
und Business Class Terminal hier kann
man es vorabflug echt ganz gut aushalten
es gibt jede Menge Essen und natürlich
ist alles im Preis mit drin gut gestärkt
ging es ins Flugzeug eine neue Boeing
Triple 7 und ich muss sagen hier sieht
alles schon etwas moderner aus als in
der alten Triple 7 von Emirates und man
hat ein bisschen mehr Privatsphäre los
geht's wie immer mit einem campagner als
Begrüßung in der Luft habe ich mir dann
ein Film reingezogen super vielfältiges
Entertainment Angebot auch viele
deutsche Filme und die neu kenzen
Kopfhörer machen einen guten Job das
Essen war auch super lecker allerdings
konnte ich nur eine Vorspeise auswählen
und das Rinderfilet als Hauptgang hat
mich nicht komplett umgehauen trotzdem
war das Erlebnis und der Service
phänomenal und ich habe mich Pudel wohl
gefühlt es war echt ein topfug und ich
würde der Business Class 8,8 von 10
Punkte geben damit liegt sie knapp
hinter der Business Class von Qatar
Airways auf Platz 2 bezahlt habe ich für
den Flug 1588 €. folgt mir doch gerne
für weitere Test